you
okay bye now you not guys know that the
tensor clock has this graph underneath
okay first question comes why do you
need a graph right why you don't just
use your programming language build the
parts tree and just use that and the
reason is because a meta graph you can
distribute it you can precisely say
where each computation is going to go
now we know now we have three different
kind of devices right we have CPU we
have a GPU and last week we have a tip
you okay so suddenly this representation
becomes very useful because you can take
one of the node and specialize
specifically for that kind of
representation these are different node
on different machines okay so we have
the different machines and now on each
of this will clean up our tents of flaw
process and the way they communicate is
with this new library G RFC G RPC are
pieces of remote procedure call so
you're able to invoke a method on
another another server we have HTTP 2 as
the connection link so we don't have the
patency of setting up the connection
which is ready sending something and
then close to the connection with the
HTTP to the connection you just trim
back and forth to the data and it's
bi-directional too so that's very
important too if you're moving big
tensors like big matrices like in neural
network is very very convenient you save
a lot of time so anything that is
between processes of course has to be
serialized and Google already
implemented something called protocol
buffer and the
we'll use it and anything that has to be
exchanged has to have has to be
serialized okay so for everything every
main object of the framework there is a
protocol inside the source code that you
can look at that and see exactly what is
being transmitted and we can look some
files later we dig inside the decode so
there is some terminology that at first
glance can be confusing we'll try to
make it more confusing so mainly we have
a cluster a cluster is made of jobs and
each job has a series of tasks okay
we usually specify the cluster in what
is a cluster specification the jobs
usually are - one is for parameter
server and one for the worker and then
for each of the jobs you have different
different tasks so it's just a list so 0
1 2 3 they don't have a particularly
name but the jobs name are important
because some as you can imagine the
worker will actually execute the
computational nodes of the graph but
some are grains you need to share some
of the variables how you will do that
you will have a parameter server so for
who of you know neural networks you have
the gradient descent step ok and that
value have to be consistent among
different nodes ok so you have let me go
back so imagine you have this 3 node
cluster and you have your graph and you
want to compute one step of your feet
forward the neural network what we will
do we will move the data and the graph
on the different nodes compute do the
the gradient descent step one on the two
different parallel nodes aggregate back
the great
is gonna do an average of the values and
then it will not redistribute the
gradient of course this works and is
valuable if this step is much more
compute intensive than transferring the
data right and now you have a bit of big
shift from big data to back to big
computation if transferring the data
takes more than your computation there
is no is there is no point in
transferring the data okay now let's get
practical an example of class
specification so in this example we have
a parameter server there is written very
little at the end of the tutorial YP s
is parameter server and then you have a
set of workers so this is the job okay
we have this job and we have one task
okay and this is another job and we have
three tasks and when we launch the
process we have to indicate given a
cluster spec what is your job and what
is your task and inside the cluster you
can have only have one that has that
task okay you can have two nodes with
Italian tasks that means no two nodes
can have worker be a worker and have to
ask indeed zero okay so the most simple
thing that you can do is this program
where you take it creates a local server
so you have two processes in your local
machine one that it has a server and one
that has a session okay and this session
will communicate to this server on on
the same node so how many how many jobs
do we have in this hello
so we have one job and one task okay
very simple and and you have a bit of
the magic going on here where the
session is gonna take this tensor
intensive flow everything is a tensor or
an operation but you just move around
tensors it's going to execute the
session is you know where are the
workers server it's going to send the
graph in this in this case the graphic
consists only of one operation is a
constant operation is just give me back
one execute and get back the values okay
this this is much clearer with this
graph okay so other other cases of a
fusing a distribute setting now why you
will really need this little boot
settings one is training okay this is
most of the time what we need having
thousands of machines because you can
paralyze a lot of this problem another
another case is hyper parameter
optimization and if you have read online
SPARC integration they started using
this one because we will talk later of
how the how you can use tensorflow and
distributed computing and then we will
look very briefly and it's insane blink
okay so this is this is a graphic I
created for trying to understand what
are the components if you have to go
down in the tensor flow space so we saw
already the server we have the cluster
specification now we know which workers
on which tasks so we have the device the
specific cheapest CPU the CPU and GPU
and then we have the session so the
session you can think and abstract it as
maintaining the state of a graph once
you run there are some side effects and
the session maintains in memory what's
going on with
all those variables okay about the
object to use is not very well marketed
but has a lot of stuff and assess your
manager coordinator and several
coordinators for the threads and you
don't really need to know much what's
what's going on and the saver is to save
the state to disk okay yes so there is
nothing of the graph here okay this is
what yeah so so it would be a
combination between the server and the
session has some state inside that
allows you to run the graph no this is
this is how the process is when you
create the nodes when you create these
nodes that's that's what is bring what
is being created inside the process
working like process in a machine non an
operation on the graph yes told you do
not confuse you more so this is a good
object to know is the session manager
and one thing that you want to do is
check pointing okay so you have your
session usually distinct runs for from
some hours two weeks okay you don't want
the cut coming by and just crashing the
machine and you lose one week of
training so one way to manually set up
all the all the check pointing and make
sure all the variables are right and all
of that and otherwise to just use the
session manager and it's going to save
the check points periodically after a
certain amount of steps on run time
and the other object is very good this
is the supervisor and this also setups
assess your manager inside so he also
handles some some other things when you
are using a distributed graph so for
some reason one day of the nodes crush
it and cannot recover it will shut down
gracefully this is this is one parameter
you have to keep in mind when you want
to run the graph this has to be the main
graph they may know that runs all the
other node in the cluster how details
that you have to go inside and and try
to to play there is no much
documentation about this but is this is
very good to actually see how how to use
this these classes yes yes the chief the
chief dies you have already the the
checkpoint so you have to rerun and
rerun the checkpoint from from the same
know if your if the chief goes down you
have to restart saying or the chief is
is the one that died okay so there are
two ways of doing the training one is
synchronous and one is a synchronous the
the nice thing with the synchronous is
all your notes just keep iterating over
the graph without actually communicating
between each other
the downside is some time the parami
some of the nodes will go lag behind the
others one now will not be at the same
speed for whatever reason maybe it's a
cloud service or one of the machine is
older and so the the variables will
start not being updated they at the same
time and this can influence the training
speed
and that's why it's useful to have a
synchronous training is of course it's
lower than the order but it gives you
more consistent result and there is this
train synchronized replicas optimizer
that will create a graph such that it
will synchronize all the other sub graph
in in time before doing the second step
no so we'll go one step across all your
network collect all the variables make
sure every every node completes compute
locally the update and send back all the
all the updated variables across the
cluster this is another handy tool that
you can use as I said before you can you
can specify you can specify exactly
where each variable is in the graph okay
so this this is our cluster we have this
is a job parameter survey we have two
tasks that's they don't ask one and we
have one job this worker and we have two
tasks okay with this syntax with
tensorflow device slash job PS / task 0
we are saying that these weights and
these biases will be handled on this
node ok so every update it would be sent
to this node and same with this other
node so you have for example task 0 and
I color-coded just to make you help on
the association right so imagine this is
this is a very simple model now imagine
if you have 10 to any variables imagine
if you were if your cluster changes is
pretty much daunting to to go there and
set it up manually all these variables
what what you want to do is that this
just use a very simple strategy and is
the replica device setter and this will
given a list of tasks in now in one of
your parameter server for example it
will assign one variable to a different
task in sequence so variable one to task
Z variable qu two task one variable
treated us three variable for back to
the schedule so enough round robin
fashion assignment so there are
different configuration that you can do
usually you want to be eaters
synchronous in graph this thesis way
we're having one graph and everything is
synchronous or you can have between
graph as singles where you have
different graph running parallel and
then you try to synchronize on the same
on the same node this is the example
with the replica device set that it will
be variable one assigned to tasks 0 were
able to task one variable three back to
task 0 because we have only two tasks I
can show very quickly so this works of
course but to prove you so this is a
very simple setup I have Chris put up
three three instances and Google Cloud
and just basic Linux instances and run
three G RPC server and and then I I run
this other script you can really read
that they will connect to to the cluster
and start training and then I I can run
another one
think so okay and so this is I will run
another one and this it has worker index
one while the other one has worker index
zero and so you will see that this this
started with a global step of 43 okay so
they are sharing what's the global step
and they are trying to synchronize and
the next thing you had to only define
the cluster okay that's the very
powerful thing because you don't have to
manually set up every single connection
maintain the the TCP and all of those
steps that you have to do before so I'm
going to show real quick what what's
they is it
so I want to show you real quick what I
love that so this is this is the graph
of the script that is running right now
okay so if it's pretty complex and as
you see is it's very detailed so you can
recognize some of the name of the
variables a global step hidden W hidden
be betatron Cali normal and these are
from this script now if you and this me
and East replica I'm gonna okay so it's
a pretty pretty involved program this is
how to train em nice that's the basic
ABC of neural network using distributed
tensorflow and you can you can find this
example inside the tents of law / tools
/ dist underscore test / Python I know
but that's why you're here because I
found it and very hard to find it even
if I look at the GT repository every day
and understand what it actually does so
some highlights here you will recognize
the device setter okay so you'll see
trying replica device setter it would do
some will create the cluster
specification okay
PS and the worker it will do other other
setups created variable has has a global
step remember to anything that is not
trainable that you just needed to
coordinate the graph II you have to set
it trainable as false because the device
will try to do some operation and it
would blow up
yes we see the synchro replicas
optimizer that we we saw it before and
then this is using another mamta miser
that currently is one among the best we
have the supervisor is chief you guys
already know all of this function and
then other other other machinery to make
all this system work I'm gonna go real
quick on on the hyper parameter
optimization so all of these are grids
as you saw for example in the optimizer
they have other variables right with it
for example learning rate but each
optimizer can have other parameter to
tweak in the way they optimize your
graph so how do you find what are the
best options for those all grips use
hyper parameter optimization okay and
last is in sampling so when a very nice
trick is to improve your performance of
your models is just you train different
models we different maybe just a
initialization weight and different
parameters and then you you and sample
them so you make them run all at the
same time with the same input and then
on the result of those different models
you choose the one that is best okay yes
yes any this comes from from statistic
were by properties of the approximator
the the sum is is better I didn't have
the time to actually saw with the other
framework one little last thing I want
to show you is what they
narrow neck was actually look like so
this this is from inception actually one
of the liars of the neural network this
is after being trained okay so our what
are what are those values is trying to
get an interpretation of what's going on
in the image okay these are just the
weights after being trained and I find
them very interesting now there is some
appealing in the image that we
synchronize somewhat with the with the
with the result now there are such a
primitive pattern that we must have
something similar